hey guys say something a bit different
today I recently had the exciting
opportunity to give a talk to a creative
writing group about working online as a
writer I spoke for a whole hour not sure
if they knew what they were letting
themselves in for but I thought it'd
record it and then that way I could
share with you guys as well so I've
split it into two parts and the first
part this part is about how to find work
online as a writer how to create a
website a bit about internet marketing
and SEO and how money is generated on
the web so I thought this could be
interesting for anyone who's interested
in becoming an entrepreneur in working
online in creating a website and adding
passive income or promoting something
that they enjoy doing in this case
creative writing and then in part two I
talked about how to stay focused and
productive even when there's lots of
distractions so I discuss things like
flow States and productivity tips and
how to overcome writer's block and
hopefully that be interesting too
because I know that quite a few of you
have actually requested a video on
concentration and motivation and I will
be covering that more in the future but
this should hopefully just be a nice
little primer I'll probably upload this
one and then something else in between
maybe workout video and then I'll upload
to parta too so I hope you found this
interesting and useful and let me know
what you think in the comments if you
have any questions etc and of course
they tune then please subscribe and like
etc and all that other stuff I'll have
much more of the usual content on the
way soon including Technology reviews
workouts brain training tips etc you
know the drill by now I would also check
out the new logo thanks a ton for
watching guys and enjoy so the reason
that a lot of people hire me in the
first place is because they need content
for their website and the more content
they have on their website the higher
they can rank in Google that often needs
keywords laced into it so the way Google
works is it has spiders these are
programs they it reads content it looks
for certain specific keywords it adds
that to a big index and that big index
it then refers to when someone searches
for something so if you search for
Fitness etc say you type in how to get
abs in ten days then somebody has
written that article and it will find it
and they'll have lace
it with that specific phrase a certain
number of times and that's what SEO is
search engine optimization it's trying
to get your content written in such a
way that it's Google friendly and if you
do look for clients online for this kind
of work then that's what they're going
to want a lot of the times they want
content that's got it laced in and
that's also a kind of whole additional
challenge in itself because SEO is
constantly changing and Google's
algorithm changes in the early days it
used to be you could just write some
content you could stuff as many of these
keywords in as you as you possibly could
and then you get to the top of Google
almost guaranteed that's not how it
works anymore today because people are
abusing that system so now it has to be
much more subtle they say there should
be 1 to 2% density maximum and use
something called LSI which is latent
semantic indexing and that means using
relevant terms synonyms etc rather than
just repeating the same phrase over and
over what you'll find is that a lot of
people are kind of pseudo experts they
don't really haven't kept up to date
with the latest but they know that it
involves stuff and lots of keywords and
so they'll say they want you know a
keyword in every single sentence and
you're like please don't do this but
yeah you got to do what the client wants
I guess but yes so that's not
particularly fun but on the other hand
these days it's turning because of these
advancements it's becoming a lot more
creative it's becoming a content
marketing which is you know well written
content because a lot of people
approached me they want me to write
content for their websites and they
clearly don't care at all about the
quality of it they're just interested in
filling it with as much as possible
covering it in ads and then hopefully
they'll make some money but then if you
look at all of the big brands online
they're not like that at all like any of
the brands that you follow of course
they're well-written they've got
something unique to say they've got like
a unique angle they're not trying to
appeal to everyone they've got a
specific demographic in mind and so the
smart clients that's what they want they
want something a little bit more
creative now written with a more
personality and more opinion and that's
a lot more fun to write and you can
often approach that in a more creative
way than you would do just the churning
out the copywriting so you can try and
tie it into something that you're
interested in you can try and give it a
more narrative angle
they say that storytelling is esier for
the human brain so they in other words
if you make say you take a really
factual boring dry topic but you talk
about how it affected you or how you
know it's changed your life etc then
that's something that's much more
readable like people like stories and
they often wants us hidden through till
the end it's got that emotional hook and
then if you're trying to sell something
as well which a lot of the clients are
then of course they've got that so there
is a kind of creative element even
though a lot of it might seem quite dry
and and non creative there is quite a
creative element to doing it so that's
kind of what you need to learn and also
persuasive writing is incredibly useful
if you want to get into that and that's
also something that can be really useful
obviously just for promoting yourself so
like I think that's probably one of the
things that helped me to have consistent
work was the quality of my original
pitches to people I've only posted four
adverts on those forums and because I
was able to pitch and the best way I
always think to angle it is kind of get
them to imagine what their website can
be and say you know they compare a
website which hires the lowest possible
fee writer and then compare that to
someone who obviously cares and has
passion and a good writing style and you
can see the difference and if you want
your website to be like that here's the
list of people I've worked with
previously yeah it makes a big
difference and I think that's how you
get hired by some people that care a
little bit more um so yeah that's a
useful skill to learn and I don't know
would anyone be interested to know the
websites that I used to find these
clients was that not something that
people would yes so there's two types of
places you can find this on the one hand
you've got the freelancer sites and then
if people are familiar with things like
Oh desk constant content is one people
per hour those are three websites where
you can sell your writing but if you're
going to do it you need to go through a
whole bunch of kind of jump - holy -
hoops you need to do tests and things
which is fair enough because they want
proof that you know what you're doing so
for instance if you say that you have an
expertise in coding or whatever then
you'll have to do a small test on coding
and also make you do a small like
grammar test to prove that you know
English kind of the sort of stuff you
might have done at school but I actually
found the
much more useful was going to webmaster
forum so these are the forms for the
marketers and this is probably why I've
dealt with some people who were just
interested in making money but they're
like the kind of online internet
marketers and they've run websites and
they're looking for content to fill it
up but they also they'll discuss other
things like SEO latest changes they'll
look for web designers etc so it's a
great place to sell work and three of
those at warrior forum blackhat forum
and digital point forum digital point
forum is the one where I first
advertised
I think blackhat forum is probably it
might be called blackhat world now
actually I think that's probably the one
at the moment this gives you the best
chance of finding some clients quite
quickly and if you write a very good
pitch there and you have a relatively
low price to begin with then you can
find pretty guaranteed work within I
would say days and you can get paid via
PayPal so you'll get money in your
account right way so if anyone has got a
writing skill and they're looking for a
way to make a little bit of extra money
on the side that's quite a convenient
way to do it and like I say you can do
creative writing there and if you want
to pitch yourself like that then that's
something you can do as well I was
saying I think it's very good if you've
got some kind of expertise some kind of
topic that you know really well for me
obviously programming was one and also
into fitness and if you could show that
you know that and if you make that your
niche and you market yourself in that
way
then hopefully you'll avoid some of the
boring stuff I had to write I've written
about car windscreens I've written about
bricklaying and like stuff I do nothing
about and had to research very quickly
and obviously the more you search it the
longer it takes to write so it's always
good if you can write something you
already know really well and you're
passionate about so yeah you could pitch
yourself as a creative writer on
somewhere like that and that would be a
good way to get started and I also think
that would be a good place for people
interested to find potential contacts
and to get more experience because like
I found that just putting stuff out
there and doing lots of work is a good
way to make contacts like on LinkedIn
and to gain the experience and then from
there you can go on to get opportunities
that you didn't expect to come from that
kind of thing
and another thing that's obviously
really useful for that is to have your
own website or blog and I think if
anyone wants to promote themselves
particularly creative writing then it
would really pay to have some kind of
outlet like that where people can follow
you and where you can
work when I was writing it writers knees
obviously a lot of the people that would
write in they wanted to publish creative
work they were poets or you know short
story writers etc and they would often
struggle to find like they obviously out
to contact an agent or a publisher first
and they often just got ignored and
speaking to the agents and the
publishers one of the things they want
to see is social proof that is a one of
the big things that can help you to get
noticed against all the other
applications that come in or the
proposals if you've got 10,000 followers
on Twitter or Facebook and they all
really like your content and that's
going to really help and so doing work
and getting yourself out there is a good
way to do that and also so is creating
your own website and that's something I
did as well I've been running my own
website in the background the bio near
where I write about fitness and
transhumanism and stuff like that and
yes so that's that's like nootropics or
technology that makes people faster or
stronger or so kind of superhero stuff
not something that is terribly in demand
for people so I have to do that yeah
well yes so the way I did it no it
doesn't have to be in fact I would
strongly recommend against anyone
building a website for several thousand
pounds if that was the review of
considering going down you can get
hosting which is the space where your
site is kept on somewhere like Bluehost
and that shouldn't cost you more than
like a 10 or a month I think for a basic
package and that's probably all you need
really to begin with and then WordPress
is a really good tool to build your site
with I built my site with WordPress and
I think it's para something like one
quarter of the Internet it's completely
free it's got a huge community around it
lots of plugins and things I think BBC
America is powered by WordPress and so
are things like Forbes and Mashable and
pretty much any big website so that's
also obviously if you're going to do
this you want to try and get word out
there as well and get your site seen
using the SEO skills that you might have
learned through writing for some of
these clients and WordPress is a like a
proven commodity in that respect because
like huge websites are powered by
WordPress so you know that it is
possible rather than building something
because I was you know being a coder I
wanted to build my own website from
scratch initially so I made it in HTML
and PHP and it was a kind of mess and so
then you never know whether the reason
that your site isn't working is because
of your content or because of the
website and it's hard whereas if you've
got if you built a site in WordPress
which is the same tool everybody uses
then you've reduced the mitigating
factors so you can narrow it down at
least it's not the code that's causing
you the problem and I got my theme from
theme forest which is yeah yeah yeah say
like yeah and I mean they look super
professional and the chances of you
coming across someone online it's got
the same one a minimal and you can edit
it yourself as well WordPress is so easy
you log in just by going to this address
and then you've got a control panel and
you can upload writing you don't need to
know how to code at all to do this and
if you want help from a professional I
I've just hired someone to create me a
new logo I used Fiverr which is so named
because everything costs $5 that's also
another place where you can sell your
work by the way
you wouldn't probably wanna do it for $5
but it starts at $5 and a lot of people
these days they have a cell barely
anything for $5 and then if you want the
basic package you actually pay $50 and
that would be a good place to sell
creative writing if that was something
you wanted to do it was just a way to
get yourself out there and start getting
some paid work yeah so I went on there
to get my lego etc and yeah you can
genuinely build a website using
WordPress and these tools in about a day
and you certainly don't need to hire a
professional web designer to spend
thousands to do that and then what you
need to do is you need to post content
on there regularly and then share that
content anywhere you can so for a
creative writer a really good place to
do that would be obviously creative
writing forums and communities maybe
reddit places like this because if
you're a bit shy about your work or
you're not sure about getting out there
than going on to these places people
will be able to see your work that they
should hopefully be friendly and also in
the same boat as you
and actually
one of the big things while trying to
get out with the whole idea of branding
versus just creating websites to try and
earn money if you can get people who are
engaged with your content and who like
really like what you're doing and who
feel like they know you that's a hundred
times better than just having it's much
better to have ten people who love your
content than it is to have a thousand
people who like you know see it every
now and then but don't really care and
so for something like this if you can
get active in the community and people
feel like they know you and then you
share your content on there they're more
like to then share other places and you
know there's a spirit of camaraderie and
stuff and that's how you then build the
momentum and then you get the other
people coming in who you know you don't
know that wouldn't have discovered your
content otherwise you wouldn't get
penalized for not updating it but
eventually it was start to drop down the
rankings it really is good if you can be
as regular as possible I mean if you've
if you posted daily that'd be fantastic
a lot of people don't have time to do
that so if you posted weekly or monthly
I mean that's better than nothing what
you do get very penalized for is posting
unoriginal content so that's one of the
reasons like I said that I gave up on
the idea of buying the setting writing
because people were there's a web
there's a website you can use to check
if content is original in Google's eyes
called copyscape if you run it through
there it will look for copies of that
content elsewhere online and if it's
duplicate then it'll flag it up so if
you sell anything like that they will
run it through there probably and if
it's duplicate they'll tell you often
you probably won't get any business from
them again but yeah Google will penalize
you if you have any duplicate content
it will also penalize you if you do try
and keyword stuff but if you wanted to
try and get your content out there as a
creative writer and you wanted to get it
seen I mean you could use aspects of
this yeah I wouldn't recommend doing
that to a large extent because you're
going to compromise the quality of your
work however if you choose a topic
that's relatively topical and if you use
the keywords say in the image titles and
in the headers in particular etc then
there's a higher chance of you turning
up higher in searches especially if you
wanted to list yourself as a writer
there's something like that that's kind
of more copywriting and there's nothing
to hurt yes
yeah so the keywords you use in your
content you the idea is that you lace it
in subtly but like I say that could
obviously compromise when they say one
to two percent density that means that
for every obviously hundred words you
would have your keyword once or twice if
it's a three word key phrase you'd have
it once or twice for every 300 or 600
words obviously that can compromise the
quality of your work so you need to be
very careful about how you do that but
you can also put it in the file name of
the website say you can put it in the
file names of the images there's meta
tags which are the descriptions that
show up in google the little snippets in
the list so places like that will help
you to show up in searches if people are
looking for you that way they do like
key words they just don't want you to
overdo it because as I said some people
like cracked the system and then they
just used so many key words that it
became unreadable so it'd be like Oh
welcome to this bye hats online shop we
hope you'd like to buy hats online buy
hats online here today and you're like
wow so they so now it has to be much
more subtle and you need to do it with
some taste which is obviously if you
have creative integrity you don't want
to be doing that anyways because it's it
really sucks when you write something
they want you to stuff keywords into it
yeah so they vary quite a lot I actually
just have a personal relationship with
my clients so they just write to me and
say this is what I like about all we do
you mean that kind of thing but they
tend to fall into several categories
they have copywriting which will be
obviously the business site writing for
the site you have the kind of more
content writing which is the blog
writing for the posts you might have
sometimes I have scripts so that's quite
creative I enjoy that for like YouTube
and I was to do that for myself as well
you have to approach each of these
things slightly differently but I'm sure
like most people would be able to figure
that out
yeah YouTube scripting is a thing and
also an explainer video so if you go
into a website that sells a certain
thing like I did work for an e post
company electronic point-of-sale which
is the software on the till which is
pretty dull for the average person and
their website at the time kind of didn't
explain what it was so you want to write
a landing page that makes that very
clear and also I wrote an explainer
video so that when song would land on
that page it would play automatically
and I'd say oh are you struggling to run
all the orders through your tilth then
you need this kind of thing just so that
somebody would immediately know what it
is so there is kind of there's kind of a
rewarding you know art to that as well
even though it's not creative in that
sense but yes I was thinking now I'd go
on and talk a little bit about how I
maintain my high output because I think
that's something people were slightly
interested in because maybe some of you
struggle to find the time to do the
writing that you want to do